one of the surprises this weekend was
not Tom Brady working out it was cut and
chisel Vladimir Putin working out this
weekend mr. Putin hitting the weights
mr. Medvedev helping out as well there
on the machines they're working out they
were vacationing in Sochi this meanwhile
it's a Russian economy tank submit the
news flow of August with oil descending
Moscow has been very quiet we need a
briefing Niel shearing his chief
emerging markets economist a capital
economics and he's won a claim on the
Russia watch joining this morning I
remember when ruble was at 70 the last
time dollar ruble panic why is there no
panic this time with ruble near 70 I
think it's been more gradual this time
last time I got to 78 collapsed they got
to Patek broke one point it got to 85
and then came back again this time has
been much more gradual it seems to
attract oil lower hence there's less
sense of panic but of course the economy
is still in a pretty bad state
the economy's in a bad state Vladimir
Putin has huge popularity I'm right do
you see his popularity wavering with is
they struggle with you can we just
starting to see the first signs in the
early polls that his popularity is
dipping there's a poll released two
weeks ago high inflation starting to eat
into that popularity mean still by far
and away the most popular of any of the
major global leaders at their home but
but just starting to see it in the may
of Pete how much is it really impacting
the economy though in the sense that
people are actually leaving Russia to go
find jobs elsewhere or they're suffering
in the sense that they don't have enough
food because the government's been able
to whip up this nationalist fever it's
really not had much of an impact in
terms of immigration people thinking
that that they're going to leave and try
and seek jobs elsewhere in fact that's
probably already happened we've seen
most the kind of educated Western right
liberals kind of leaving that that's
probably happened that the people that
stayed at home not much impact on
migration flows but of course real wages
are collapsing 10% time let me bring in
Carl Rico Donna with us this morning
from Bloomberg intelligence Carl I know
you've looked at how Russia dovetails
into hydrocarbon economics and also
frankly into our international relations
sure absolutely I mean that the key here
is exchange rates matter this it should
be the lesson for all central bankers
whether they're Russian us or
your European or Japanese the move in
the currency is confident very
significant inflation I'm gonna go to
Ian Bremmer in a g0 world is Russia part
of the g7 or the g8 are they an emerging
market would you cover Neil or are they
a frontier economy was the only it
depends how you define it in terms of
income standards there's somewhere
between emerging market develop market
in terms of quite on the global stage I
think they have almost none knife really
you would say none I think that
certainly looks awfully good in that
white t-shirt well this is it's become a
tradition every August we get Vladimir
Putin you know saving Tigers fishing
with bear back time for them to swap
roles again when does he become med
video so there's another election in
2018 but he'll know he could serve a
second term okay so how are they
managing to keep the ruble oh it's six
is it where are two and a half percent
week or so versus the dollar again today
but why is completely collapsed but but
bear in mind that a weaker ruble
actually helps the government to some
extent because it increases the local
currency value of their oil revenues so
all's priced in dollars ruble collapses
the ruble value of those or revenues
goes up so that the moment the public
price has been on the strength of their
banks I've been watching personally just
to see when the banks finally blink do
you just assume a bailout by Moscow I
think that will that will happen yes I
mean that the the way that the the the
banks it's a structured big five banks
are safe the mid tier banks are the ones
to watch
they're the vulnerable ones I suspect
they'll just get bailed out but one of
the bigger banks when you look at
emerging markets I mean August what a
month it's been when you write for
September what will be your tone across
all emerging markets it's it's strange
if you went back three months ago I tell
you that the consensus was wildly
optimistic and optimistic on the
prospects for emerging markets in the
last literally in the last four weeks
things are switched around I think
they're now too pessimistic
how can how can real gdp be minus 3.7
and CPI be more than 15% and there be
only 6% unemployment are those
statistics just well better at the
moment we were at the stage where firms
are hoarding workers but bear in mind
that the pain has not been felt in
unemployment has been felt in the
collapse in real wages so people are
keeping their jobs but their income cut
very quickly which nation are you
following is a
this paper for the global system is it
Brazil like so many others Brazil China
I think the really interesting one to
look keep an eye on is Mexico because
that's gonna really tell you how quickly
the US economy is recovering and the
strength of US demand lifted you have a
tip point on currency met quickly here
in Mexico at seventeen deserve a further
weaker peso there's a tip point I think
we're podium and Polly may be at the
bottom we're at the bottom now I know
sure and thank you so much with capital
economics on emerging markets